Okay.
Just give me like,
uh,
right now we're on the eastern right now.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Or Live Ladies and gentlemen,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link that says fleshlight entering the code name Brogan.
You get 15% off.
All right.
And with that said,
buckle up bitches.
Here we go.
Joe Diaz is in the motherfucking house.
Oh yeah.
[inaudible]
a lot of people been complaining that this is lame music.
A lot of people.
Yeah,
and saying,
you know,
this song is just not befitting of such a fucking dynamic podcast.
Why you got some fucking fruity tooty tunes playing there?
Why don't you got some?
Because we don't want,
first of all,
we don't want the song to overshadow the show.
What if the song is better than the show?
And you're like,
why don't you fuck stop talking and play some more of that groovy music you
would just hitting me with Joe Diaz is in the mother fucking house,
bitches,
baby.
That's all you need to know.
Forget about that Goddamn opening music.
Don't be tripping.
Don't beat Paul.
Don't get Joe Shit to give a kid.
The best is when somebody complains about that song and then they send you their
like keyboard.
Oh,
there's songs of Daphne and they'll send it to you a thousand times and kids
just like case you didn't get it the first 50,000 times when I sent it.
This is a new one.
I've,
I've put some echo to the drums.
It's a little bit different.
No,
it's great.
That's great.
Did you dude?
Dude,
dude to too,
I'm ready to leave Joe Diaz.
If this fucking earthquake comes,
I'm gone.
Baby.
Back to the mountains with the full posse.
Load them up in the Lexus.
Leave everything behind how little locations in this country.
You got San Francisco,
Oregon,
California and Nashville.
One of the points is the fault on that.
We,
well,
there's other faults.
There's a fault near New York,
right?
Does the Fort New York,
yeah.
There's,
there's a bunch of false man.
It's like the,
here's the deal.
Honestly,
we know what,
what moves on a regular basis.
If it,
that doesn't preclude things from,
from moving on,
uh,
you know,
unique basis.
There could be some fucking new shit that happens anyway.
We don't,
we don't have this shit wired.
We don't know what the hell is going on.
There's some recent study with these scientists are going to drill into the
earth's mantle all the way through the fucking core.
It's going to take five to try to figure out how to do it.
It's like they're like little kids.
It's like,
well we know we can't use a regular drill because it'll melt,
you know,
so they're trying to figure out how the fuck they're going to get a drill.
The drills all the way down to the mat and you ask them why,
what are you doing?
You're going to,
is there a leprechauns down there?
They're going to give you gold.
What's going on is they're aliens down there.
They're going to suck your Dick.
What are you doing?
Why are you drilling down to the mantle?
Because people are silly fucks and we just want to see what's up.
We just want to see what's up.
We want to try what's up.
Sometimes you got to dig a hole.
The fun stuff.
Yeah,
but what the fuck man?
What if they dig a hole through the earth mantle and the earth becomes like a
fucking balloon with a hole in it and just goes flying around the galaxy?
What if it lava shoots out of it like she like a balloon.
You know how you go and your blow the balloon,
then you let it go.
How about that?
What if the earth becomes like that?
Like a balloon that doesn't does not tied off at the end and the earth flies
around the galaxy.
I'll fucking haphazardly like a balloon.
What did we find out?
The earth is really made out of rubber and this whole mantle and all this other
bullshit.
This is just outside the balloon.
This is like the decoration on the balloon,
but if you pop that mother fucker it was just fly around Jupiter.
Yeah,
we slamming a Jupiter and shit and we slam it.
Other planets,
that's is the most fucked up thing about spaces that occasionally planets hit
each other.
God Damn Son.
Could you imagine what kind of chaos there would be in this world if we saw a
planet common our way,
if you saw a Mars like for sure Mars is coming,
it might take five years,
but it's going to hit the earth and we're fucked in.
There's not a God damn thing we can do to stop it.
There it is.
You see it in the sky gets a little bigger every night.
By the time it got real close,
people would be losing their fucking mind.
It'd be fucking great.
It wouldn't be a party,
you know,
warrior with knives and stabbing people.
It would be like that scene in event horizon.
You remember that movie event horizon with Laurence Fishburne?
You don't remember that Badass fucking science fiction movie.
Sam Shepard and I think it's Sam Shepard and Laurence Fishburne and it's about a
of spaceship that punches a hole through a wormhole.
They traveled to a distant part in the galaxy by folding the space and time
together,
like two pieces of paper,
punching a hole through it in a,
in a arriving on the other end.
But when they did that,
they didn't realize that they actually went to hell.
So these guys get to this,
uh,
event horizon ship.
It comes back,
everyone's dead,
and they get a video of a,
the,
the crew and the,
uh,
the captain and everything.
Like they find out later in the movie what happened to them and they're pulling
their own eyeballs out and scream and shit and Latin and killing each other and
biting each other apart and cotton each other open.
That's what it's going to look like.
It's not gonna be like,
everyone's like,
we're going to be,
fuck it.
You're not going to be fucking okay.
When there's bars,
it's like a hundred times bigger than the moon.
Maybe a thousand to,
I don't know.
What the fuck am I doing?
I think,
I think I would fucking kill myself.
I would close my fucking eyes and wish for the best.
I'm not tapping out that fucking easy.
Can you pull up that song?
Dream weaver.
Did you pull up that side now pull that song.
It's too early for that shit.
We gotta establish the show first.
You're gonna hit it with this gave using.
Now I want to hear you.
I want to hear what you would do.
I want to hear what you would do over that song.
Not a want of them.
Nothing.
First of all,
that shit wouldn't happen to know
if I see shit come in,
I just go home.
You can get stuck up on some fucking earth.
Get some good books and wait for the ship to drop.
Go like,
wait,
what are you guys?
Don't do?
You gotta get on the four or five with these fucking idiots and you know what
are you going to go get on a one 10 guys with helicopters who have just be
pissing in your head,
out of their helicopter laughing at you.
You're stuck in this stupid grid though.
There won't be no fucking helicopters is,
hey,
doesn't this fucking city you got?
There'll be those helicopters.
Yeah,
I'll be shooting you down.
We'll go and we're gone.
We're gone.
It's going to be fucking chaos.
Yeah.
You know,
it's interesting.
People didn't really learn about human behavior from the Rodney king riots,
but that's what should have taught you.
This is what's possible with something so simple as a verdict for someone who
you don't even know who you saw get beat up and they let the cops go,
and these mother fuckers were going crazy,
throwing rocks at white people.
Smash their fucking and yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was a racially charged issue.
I understand that people have this feeling of a,
an unfair society and it's set up.